[Música]
más casos de brutalidad policial
estremecen a eeuu ya sacudido desde hace
meses por históricas protestas contra el
racismo y la violencia por parte de los
agentes en washington un hombre
afroamericano murió este miércoles por
disparos de los elementos de seguridad y
en nueva york' se hizo público otro acto
de violencia policial
segunda jornada del histórico juicio en
el que francia revive los violentos
ataques terroristas del 2015 en los que
17 personas murieron el proceso se lleva
a cabo con fuertes controles de
seguridad medidas sanitarias como el uso
obligatorio de cubrebocas y testimonios
de las víctimas que son filmados tenemos
reporte desde el palacio de justicia en
el norte de parís
por las medidas contra la pandemia
bolivia no puede ir al teatro pero su
música viaja a las casas les presentamos
una nueva entrega de nuestros informes
especiales sobre la cultura en tiempos
del hobbit 19 hoy vamos a la paz
hola cómo están muy buenos días en
américa latina' ya todos ustedes que nos
siguen por la señal de france 24 mi
nombre es alan austria sean bienvenidos
y es que empezamos en la capital de eeuu
donde un hombre afroamericano murió este
miércoles por disparos de agentes de
seguridad el jefe de policía de
washington dijo que sus agentes estaban
en la parte sureste de la capital para
investigar reportes de hombres armados
en un vehículo y que al acercarse a
algunas personas huyeron y un policía
abrió fuego dejando a un joven
afroestadounidense muerto esto en la
capital mientras en nueva york' se hizo
público ayer otro acto de violencia
policial ocurrido hace cinco meses
cuando un hombre afroamericano falleció
después de que agentes de la policía de
rochester lo detuvieron y le presionaron
su cabeza contra el pavimento hasta
provocar una asfixia el hecho se produjo
el 23 de marzo la víctima daniel blood
de 41 años murió una semana después el
30 de marzo pero su caso fue dado a
conocer hasta ahora por su familia que
ha presentado varios vídeos del suceso
aprecio a la familia porque están
frustrados en este momento
reding azul pero tenga la seguridad de
que haremos todo lo posible para
asegurarnos de que la verdad salga a la
luz y se haga justicia la justicia
francesa inicia hoy el segundo día del
juicio contra los 14 supuestos cómplices
de los ataques terroristas contra el
semanario satírico charlie hebdo y un
supermercado judío en parís en enero del
2015 en los que 17 personas murieron
desde el palacio de justicia poco de
clichy en el norte de la capital nuestra
periodista erika olavarría nos da los
detalles de esta jornada
menos preciosa y menos público en este
segundo día de los 49 que debe durar
este proceso por los atentados de enero
del año 2015 en parís - público pero más
policía alrededor de este edificio del
palacio de justicia aquí en la puerta de
clichy donde se han establecido
diferentes entradas ya sea para la
prensa para los abogados de la parte
civil y para el público eso sobre todo
después de la publicación nuevamente por
saliendo de las caricaturas de mahoma y
este segundo día de juicio estado
dedicado a conocer la personalidad de
los 11 acusados que están presentes en
este juicio pero al comienzo ha habido
muchos problemas de audio recordemos que
este juicio se realiza en una sala pero
es repetido en otras cinco por lo tanto
es muy importante que se escuche bien en
esos lugares donde hay testigos donde
hay parte civil y donde también está la
prensa tras perder muchos minutos en eso
escuchamos el testimonio de abdel aziz
abad él está acusado de pertenecer al
grupo que consiguió armas tanto para
médico y bali y los hermanos que allí
está acusado también de haber tenido
pacto con uno de ellos él se dice
inocente dice que es una persona que
creció en un hogar musulmán que esta es
una religión de paz no de matar personas
y dice saber el dolor que está pasando a
las familiares de las víctimas los
sobrevivientes y compartirlos
el gobierno del presidente de rusia
vladimir putin mostró su disposición a
cooperar con alemania en el caso del
líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni pero
puso en duda que éste fuera envenenado
con nowitzki esta sustancia que fue
creada entre los 70 y 80 en la unión
soviética poco detectable que puede
causar la muerte y que no es la primera
vez que resuena en todo el mundo andrés
meza muñoz no se explica que es el
novillo
es un nombre poco común y muy rara vez
se escucha hablar de él no [__] que un
agente nervioso y letal detectado en el
organismo del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni según expertos hace parte de una
familia de sustancias químicas que en la
década de los 60 eran utilizadas como
insecticida este este medicamento pues
actúa principalmente en el sistema
nervioso autónomo y también puede
afectar a los músculos la intoxicación
principalmente se caracteriza por
salivación broncoespasmo e hipotensión
que ayuda a la tensión arterial y
también puede terminar en paro cardíaco
y a nivel muscular puede haber parálisis
muscular lo que lleva a un paro
respiratorio que es lo que finalmente
causa la muerte es la misma sustancia
que en 2018 puso en coma al ex espía
ruso serguéi skripal y a su hija giulia
el reino unido- y aunque ambos se
recuperaron cuatro meses después una
mujer murió tras haber estado expuesta
al novillo
letalidad va a depender de la dosis
estos pueden actuar tan rápido como 510
segundos y matar a una persona en 15
minutos tal vez pero todo depende de la
cantidad que llegue al cuerpo y de la
forma como ingresé puede ser a través de
la piel puede ser a través de las vías
respiratorias este tipo de arma química
fue creada por la unión soviética en las
décadas de los 70 y 80 pero no son los
únicos capaces de desarrollarla en los
componentes y la síntesis de estos
productos no es tan compleja y podría
ser preparado en cualquier país
donde se disponga de los elementos que
prácticamente en cualquiera ellos de
acuerdo con expertos en armas químicas
el novillo que es poco detectable y está
diseñado para superar las capacidades de
defensa química de la otan
el kobe 19 también envió a cuidados
intensivos a la economía peruana y es
que además de tener la tasa de
mortalidad más alta del mundo la nación
andina lidera la crisis económica
mundial con una contracción trimestral
mayor al 30 por ciento en su producto
interno bruto muchas empresas han
cerrado y millones de personas se han
quedado sin empleo nuestro corresponsal
en lima francisco zacarías nos relata
como el confinamiento le cobra una
costosa cuenta a los peruanos
a marta morales la invade en los
recuerdos las pérdidas y las deudas
contraídas debido al confinamiento su
restaurante quebró y 19 familias se
quedaron sin sustento económico tener la
continuidad de un restaurante abierto
pues fue bastante trabajo lo que se hizo
es que luchó y se mantuvo pero ahorita
así graves gran nos vemos así como
martha muchos empresarios tuvieron que
cerrar sus negocios pero se encuentra
oficialmente en recesión en el segundo
trimestre del año su producto bruto
interno se redujo en 30.2 por ciento
como consecuencia de la estricta
cuarentena impuesta para contener la
pandemia del cob y 19 las autoridades
han reconocido que el duro retroceso
para que este 2020 su economía tenga una
caída del 12% estamos en una recesión y
con peligro de que se convierta en una
depresión
nos quedemos mucho tiempo sin poder
volver a crecer a tasas normales
esto porque hay un entrampamiento la
economía peruana casi 7 millones de
peruanos perdieron sus empleos los
expertos consideran que esto generará
más informalidad en el trabajo y mayor
pobreza los ciudadanos vislumbra un
futuro incierto están quebrando el
personal está siendo despedido los
hogares están en una situación económica
muy triste no hay para los alimentos de
la familia pero ser un comerciante
independiente simplemente me quedé en la
calle viajo todo mi capital pero
teníamos que comer la verdad porque no
tiene trabajo no podía salir a vender no
puede hacer nada simplemente me quedé me
casé encerrado meses tres meses
para mí fue una decisión acertada la
cuarentena ahora de que no se hizo bien
si eso tenía hay que aceptarlo no se
hizo bien muchas cosas no por ejemplo el
tema de la de los bonos
marta ha decidido reinventarse como
consultora de belleza que es la otra
cara de un perú que no se rinde ante la
adversidad
y nos vamos a venezuela donde la
oposición se divide tras las
negociaciones con el gobierno de nicolás
maduro que liberan a presos políticos
ayer el líder opositor henrique capriles
rompió sus lazos con el bloque que
encabeza juan guaidó el presidente de la
asamblea nacional e incluso invitó a
participar en las elecciones
parlamentarias previstas para el próximo
6 de diciembre es por ello que enlazamos
con la corresponsal de france 24 en
caracas buenos días por ahí en la
capital herminia fernández la decisión
de capriles de ir a las elecciones que
'tanto fractura la oposición venezolana
y por qué se quiere desligar del
proyecto de unidad de juan guaidó
sí buenos días a la la digamos las
declaraciones de ayer de henrique
capriles lo que hacen es fracturar más a
la oposición ya venía fragmentada antes
de que cuando se convirtiera en líder
opositor en enero del 2019 son cuatro
las personas que durante los últimos
años son las caras visibles de la
oposición que son juan guaidó y leopoldo
lópez que están unidos en esta idea del
cese al usurpación que no ha funcionado
hasta el momento también maria corina
machado que es de las que opina que
deben venir fuerzas extranjeras al país
para sacar a nicolás maduro y ahora de
jett abril es que es el que está de
parte de asistir a las elecciones
legislativas en diciembre para como dice
el entrar por una brecha y ganar
espacios al gobierno de nicolás maduro
todos tienen y de pintas sacar quieren
sacar a nicolás maduro pero no llega a
un acuerdo juan guaidó ha dicho esta
semana que presentará al país su
propuesta de una la oposición pese a
esta nueva idea que ha propuesto
henrique capriles y que prefiere luchar
a no luchar como le dije antes que
quiere aprovechar esta brecha
para entrar de alguna manera a la
asamblea nacional y también quieres que
aprovechar la oportunidad de que el
gobierno llamado luego de 14 años a la
unión europea y al lado y al a la onu
para que participen como observadores
internacionales en estas elecciones de
diciembre habrá que esperar estos
próximos días que faltan pocos
y poco tiempo para que se pueda
inscribir las personas para estas
elecciones a ver si realmente la
posición va a seguir lo que capriles ha
decidido el día de ayer bien pues muchas
gracias por tu reporte herminia
fernández si nos vamos a otros temas y
es que las autoridades argentinas
divulgaron los resultados de la autopsia
que determinó que el cuerpo hallado hace
dos semanas corresponde al del joven
facundo astudillo castro quien había
desaparecido el 30 de abril nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- natalio
cos hoy nos dio detalles de este caso
el juzgado a cargo de la investigación
por la desaparición de facundo astudillo
castro confirmó que unos restos hallados
a mediados de agosto en una zona rural
del sur de la provincia de buenos aires-
se corresponden con el joven de 22 años
así lo determinó una evaluación del
equipo argentino de antropología forense
facundo astudillo castro había
desaparecido el 30 de abril pasado
cuando viajaba desde la localidad de
pedro luro donde vivía en el sur de la
provincia de buenos aires- hacia la
cercana ciudad de bahía blanca para
visitar a su ex novia nunca llegó y su
familia no supo más de él en el camino
había sido detenido por la policía de la
provincia de buenos aires- y la familia
justamente señala a esta fuerza como
posible responsable de lo que le ocurrió
al joven y ahora será tarea de la
justicia determinar exactamente qué
ocurrió con facundo astudillo castró
cómo y por qué murió y por qué sus
restos terminaron en esa zona rural de
la provincia de buenos aires- cercana a
la ciudad de bahía blanca
cuarta entrega de informes sobre la
cultura en medio de la pandemia
vamos a bolivia con nuestra corresponsal
mary ibaka quien nos tiene la historia
[Música]
después de varios meses sin tocar debido
al confinamiento obligatorio por la
pandemia la banda boliviana gustavo
orihuela quartet vuelve a un escenario
aunque lo hace en un teatro adaptado
para transmisiones en directo y sin
butacas estamos súper contentos
volvamos al escenario aunque no sea con
el contacto directo con la gente si bien
esta nueva modalidad virtual nos permite
estar propagar nos un poco más no
podemos llegar a varios países el teatro
nuna ha invertido para innovar en la
tecnología y la capacitación de su
personal para las emisiones en streaming
nosotros queremos realmente simular lo
que es venir al teatro lo que era venir
al teatro antes de la pandemia que es
vivir las obras en tiempo presente y el
tiempo presente
es algo que permite ver la capacidad del
artista de improvisar desde su casa la
periodista isabel nadie lamenta perderse
la experiencia en vivo pero asegura que
ha sido compensada por la calidad de la
transmisión
el tiempo que esta banda le ha gustado
se ha tomado para
lanzarse de nuevo en este otro formato
les ha servido porque está su primera
actuación desde el una en él
en streaming me ha parecido que ha sido
muy bien lograda
en tiempos de pandemia no podemos ir al
teatro pero la música viene a nuestra
casa para que sigamos consumiendo
cultura y así será por mucho tiempo en
bolivia porque continúan prohibidos los
espectáculos públicos gracias siguen
france24
[Música]